okay so thank you it's really a
privilege to be here it's such a great
meeting with so many people thinking
deeply about the same problems but I
want to tell you about is some of our
work on related problems looking at
tumor evolutions of tumor phylogenetics
in particular with regard to copy number
variations so I suppose it doesn't need
to be said anymore at this point that
cancer is an evolutionary phenomenon and
this insight that understanding cancer
is fundamentally about understanding and
reconstructing evolutionary systems led
20 years ago to a body of work offering
the crucial insight that if
reconstructing cancer is about
reconstructing evolution then we can
take advantage of the enormous machinery
of phylogenetics the computational
biologists have put together over the
years for understanding evolutionary
systems so that led to a body of work by
the author's shown here and I actually
wanted to pause to offer a really
interesting and exciting anecdote that
was told to me just a few days ago by
Alejandro Shafer who is one of the
authors of this original work as well as
one of my collaborators today so
Alejandro when I told him I was coming
to this meeting told me that me that by
an incredible coincidence exactly 20
years ago this week the field of tumor
phylogenetics was born right here at
Berkeley came out of a meeting between
Alejandro and christos papadimitriou so
it's really especially a privilege to be
back here at the birthplace of tumor
phylogenetics on its 20th anniversary to
talk about it but the original
conception of tumor phylogenetics what's
known as onco genetics was the idea that
we could represent a tumor evolution by
treating tumors as if they were species
and by building evolutionary trees among
these species discover meaningful
groupings among tumors as well as
identify key decision points and the
development of different subtypes of
tumors in the 20 years since this was
first proposed this has of course become
an enormous area of study bringing in
many researchers from any different
areas looking at a variety of directions
related to this a lot of the work is
since shifted from these models of
looking at many tumors in a single
evolutionary tree to trying to
understand evolution in single patience
and a lot of that work it falls more or
less into the
category regional phylogenetics and
we've seen many examples of this where
you look at different tumor sites or
regions within an individual so regional
sections of single tumors or multiple
tumors in a patient and try to
reconstruct evolutionary trees as in
this example here my own lab had
introduced the third approach to tumor
phylogenetics which is phylogenetics of
single tumor cell populations to
populations of single tumor cells
isolated from individual biopsies and
trying to build evolutionary trees on
those cell populations and all of these
directions have led to a great deal of
additional work since their first
proposed but I want to tell you a bit
about some of the directions we've been
looking at at single-cell phylogenetics
in particular looking at single-cell
phylogenetics from copy number
variations so we've been looking at this
using what now has become an atypical
kind of data for this work fluorescence
in situ hybridization or fish most of
the work going on in this area today is
using some variant of single cell
sequencing but I'd like to argue that
fish actually gives you a really
important window into this phenomena
that no other technology available to us
can give us at this at present so for
anyone not familiar with fish fish is
basically just a way of fluorescently
labeled genome and by counting copy
numbers fish probes we can track events
of gain or loss of these genomic regions
and tumors as they evolve and this is a
really key kind of marker for tumor
development because most tumors have
some kind of chromosome instability
phenotype that leads to a very rapid
gain or loss of genomic regions a lot of
structural variation and indeed the
structural variation manifesting as copy
number changes is the primary way that
tumors progress because of this being
able to monitor this tumor progression
process gives you a lot of power for
understanding how these tumors are
evolving so fish has some significant
disadvantages and some significant
advantages relative to other approaches
and the main disadvantage is that you
get to see very little purcell the state
of the art is about 10 to 15 fish probes
per cell so you're monitoring copy
numbers of a small number of genes in a
single cell the main advantage is
scalability fish is much chief
and easier than sequencing technologies
so it's possible to get hundreds to
thousands of cells and single tumors and
to do this on scales of tens to hundreds
of tumors so you can get a kind of data
that is very limited in some ways very
powerful in others and I hope to
convince you that this is a really
crucial window in tumor development so
when we first started doing this it was
based on relatively early fish data sets
where we were able to see just two
probes per cell and it turns out that
even two probes Purcell is enough to
reveal what have since become some of
the major observations of tumor
heterogeneity and phylogenetic studies
in particular that tumors are far from
homogeneous masses even with just two
probes you begin to see different
populations of tumors for example in
this histogram of copy numbers of two
different probes on cell populations
extracted from a single tumor and that
suggested that we could look at these
populations and try to build
evolutionary trees modeling how these
different populations could have risen
from an initial diploid cell for a
simple set of data like this this is
something where you could almost do this
by hand if you have little knowledge of
the mechanisms of copy number variation
and you can do this in populations and
start to put together models of kind of
consensus networks of the major pathways
of evolution across tumors and even from
these early data sets we could start to
reconstruct some of these differences of
mechanisms of evolution among different
tumors and how these differ tumor to
tumor and sometimes even cell lineage to
cell lineage and single tumors the data
has since gotten much better and that's
a both a blessing and a curse if you're
a computational biologist this is an
illustration of a more recent data set
where we have now eight probes per tumor
so each of the rows here corresponds to
one gene that's profiled in this 2012
data set from our collaborators green
means gain red means loss blue means
it's diploid and each column corresponds
to a single cell so this is about 200
single cells in the top diagram here
about 110 in the bottom diagram and the
key points I want to illustrate with
this our first of all you get a very
heterogeneous picture we can kind of see
that there's more or less one dominant
clone
here but that's only about a third of
the tumor about another third is other
reasonably well represented clones and
about another third just looks like
random noise almost as if the tumor were
trying everything and that's a pretty
typical profile for these tumors so this
in particular is one example of a ductal
carcinoma in situ is an early
precancerous stage of breast cancer and
here we see a similar profile from an
invasive ductal carcinoma more advanced
stage and one of the key points that
these revealed to us is that if you want
to understand tumor evolution you need
to be able to do your phylogenetics for
fairly large numbers of cells there's a
lot of complexity there and you can't
characterize it with just even a few
major clonal populations the other
important point that we observe when we
look at these is illustrated by
comparing these because one thing I
haven't added here is that these
actually came from the same patient this
is a DC is and an IDC taken from a
single breast cancer patient and again
we see a fairly typical profile that the
complexity we see here is quite
different from what we see in the later
stage the major clone here is actually a
minor clone in the later stage what's
the most dominant clone in later stage
is something we don't see it all here
although may have evolved from the
original major clone and when you look
across populations of tumors what you
see is that almost any combination of
relationships between early and late
will be found in some tumors sometimes
the major clone early remains the major
clone late sometimes a minor clone early
expands to become the major clone late
sometimes what dominates the late tumor
seems to come from nowhere probably this
noise region and something we're not
even seeing and you see all of these
variations when you start looking at
different patients so what all that is
suggesting is that if we want to
understand tumor evolution we need to be
able to do phylogenetics of relatively
complicated data sets we can't ignore
the minor noise we really need to take
advantage of and embrace this complexity
so to do this we wanted to try to get
into some ways of building phylogenies
on these more complicated data sets and
as you would often do in your theorist
the way you try to get started is you
try to take a
back from the biology see if you can
come up with a relatively simple model
you can get a handle on theoretically
see what you can do with that and then
start improving that I want to do for
most of this talk is kind of walk you
through some stages of that and the
things we learn as we go through it as a
first pass to this we decided to propose
a very simple model of copy number
evolution and pretend the copy numbers
change by gain or loss of isolated
probes a one probe of one gene on one
chromosome gets gained or lost we know
that's an oversimplification but it's a
starting point and it lets us pose a
simple computational problem we can
model each cell we observe as a point on
a grid where each coordinate corresponds
to copy number of one probe and then the
problem of building most plausible
phylogenetic trees is simply the problem
of filling in unobserved cell types to
link things together with as few
mutations as possible a few of these
mutational events and once we do that we
then have a model and as is typical with
the rework we can then start to ask does
this remind us of anything we already
know how to think about and for anyone
who knows their phylogenetics you would
probably recognize that this is a
specialized version of phylogenetics
it's actually a very well studied
problem called the rectilinear minimum
Steiner tree problem and there's more
than 50 years of theory on solving
rectilinear minimum Steiner tree
problems now the reason for this isn't
because people were working on tumor
phylogenetics 50 years ago it's because
people were working on integrated
circuit design 50 years ago and that's
kind of the beauty of theory that when
you step back to the right level of
abstraction often you can recognize that
even though no one has worked on your
real world problem before they might
have worked on your abstraction of it
before so that gave us a lot of tools we
could use to make this problem at least
tractable and practice throw in some
other heuristics from the phylogenetic
literature and come up with ways of
building phylogenetic trees on
relatively complicated data sets of a
few hundred cells per tumor such as in
this primary tumor and this metastases
from set of cervical cancer cases I know
you can't see what's going on the
individual boxes but if you blow up a
few each of these corresponds to one
cell type so one vector of copy number
values essentially we can also work with
some
more complex data set so these are the 8
pro breast cancer data sets and here you
start getting enough complexity that you
can almost feel you can tell stories
about the evolution of these tumors kind
of see an initial cell you get some
diversification expansion into a more
diverse population passes through some
kind of selective bottleneck which leads
to a huge explosion and diversity and
then maybe there's another of these
selective bottlenecks coming up later
see a similar picture apparently in this
IDC case and other kinds of tumors we
can sort of tell similar stories this is
showing a couple of prostate cancers
where we've got a non progressor someone
that didn't go on to metastasize and a
professor and again we can serve tell a
story of how here we kind of see a
diversification that never really goes
anywhere generates lots of diversity
here in the progressor we see that
diversification leading to eventually
drilling deeper on some aspect of the
phylogeny and we can think that maybe
we're seeing something that's telling us
about how it is that this became a
progressor well this one didn't but I'd
actually like to caution that that kind
of storytelling I think is not a
particularly good way to do two more
phylogenetics and indeed when you look
at patient populations and you look at
the different phylogenies any of these
trends you think you see any of these
stories you think you can tell on one
tumor you look at the next tumor and
it's completely different so really if
you want to get this to work what you
have to do is not just build a few
phylogenies and start telling stories
you need to start asking what can we
actually find among these phylogenies
among populations of patients that is in
some sense statistically robust some of
this you can try to do more or less
doing phylogeny assisted ways of our
kind of classic studies of selection
trying to identify drivers and
passengers in fish you only have drivers
because you only get a few probes and
despite many attempts by me we have not
convinced our collaborators to put on
probes that aren't known to be important
to cancer so we only get driver probes
to work with and we can at least see
which of these are unka genes which are
tumor suppressors which ones are
selectively acting a particular stages
of mutation so are there some there
selectively active in metastasis versus
primary tumors or in late stages versus
precancerous stages but really what I
think is more interesting about these
phylogenies is what we can learn about
the overall evolutionary process so you
might have noticed why I was trying to
tell those stories that I could try to
tell stories about the overall
evolutionary dynamics of a tumor even
when we were zoomed out so much that you
couldn't actually see the individual
genes and that's something that comes up
very often in these phylogenies many
genes will support the same story about
the evolution of a tumor and we can at
least reason that you should be able to
see overall effects things like the
balance of diversification and selection
selective bottlenecks and so forth from
overall topological features of these
trees rather than these gene centric
kind of focuses and that turns out to be
more than just a mechanism of
storytelling you can actually extract
robust statistics of these trees that
distinguished in different tumors or
tumor stages so for example in the
cervical cancers this is showing a way
of plotting a topological feature of the
tree something I capture is whether
we're looking at a broad tree a narrow
tree a shallow tree a deep tree what it
is essentially is asking what fraction
of cells followed each depth in a given
tree and this turns out to be across
multiple tumor types a robust
distinguishing feature between primary
and metastatic tumors the primaries
primarily get broad and stay broad the
metastatic tumors broaden and then
narrow which we can kind of say after
the fact we think probably is reflecting
stronger selection on a metastasis
relative to a primary tumor although
that is just a hypothesis we can't
really prove that but whether or not we
can prove that we can use these kinds of
observations to make robust predictions
about tumor progression processes and
that I think is a lot of the real power
of these tumor phylogenetic methods we
can use those kinds of topological
features as a way of clustering tumors
and show the clustering tumors on these
typologies allow statistically robust
separations of long surviving versus
short surviving tumors
an example from head and neck cancers
where we can show that you can separate
tumors into two subgroups it with a
statistically significant survival
difference and more than that you can
show that this is providing independent
information beyond what's already
available to the clinician so there's
still a weekly significant effect even
after you count for tumor staging and
smoking behavior what the clinician
would usually be using to try to make a
prognosis on these kinds of patients so
the evolutionary process is encoding
predictive information about the
progression of the tumor there are other
ways of showing that we've sought to
develop a a body of work on using some
basic kinds of machine learning methods
to show how you can take this
phylogenetic information and determine
predictive features of tumors through a
kind of classification paradigm so in
other words we can ask what it is that's
different between the phylogeny of a
primary tumor and a metastasis so this
is showing a set of classification
experiments using support vector
machines to ask that question and the
key point here is that a set of features
extracted from these phylogenies
basically properties of the evolutionary
tree have stronger predictive power for
distinguishing a primary tumor from a
metastasis then do the raw experimental
data or more modern kind of measures of
overall heterogeneity that have been
previously shown by others to be
predictive of progression the a good
model the evolution gives you more power
than heterogeneity alone and certainly
more power than the experimental data
even more exciting you can actually
robustly classify just from looking at
the primary whether you're looking at a
primary that progressed store a primary
that did not progress and this is
something we can only do with the
phylogenetic data these other datasets
to other data sources without the
phylogeny model do no better than chance
the phylogenetic models give us robust
predictions about 80% and as we'll see
later you can't get that to one hundred
percent but you can boost it a little
more as we go further in this process
but essentially what this is showing us
is that even a relatively simple model
of the tumor evolution process can give
us good enough phylogeny is close enough
to some biological ground truth that
they have predictive power for future
progression now of course that is a very
crude model and that's just the
beginning of a long process of trying to
bring that ever closer to the actual
biology and one of the next steps which
is reflected and I think many of the
other talks here is to try to get that
closer to the actual combination of
mechanisms by which copy numbers evolve
so we don't just have single probes or
single localized regions getting gained
or lost we have a multi state or a
multiscale process in which you can have
change of the level of whole chromosomes
or large pieces of chromosomes whole
genomes and if you don't account for all
of this you're not going to get an
accurate model of how the tumor is
evolving so our next step was to try to
ask can we take that first pass and then
bring this towards a more realistic
model the actual multiscale of nature of
tumor evolution and I felt it would be
remiss to come to the Simon's institute
for theoretical computer science and not
at least say that an enormous amount of
theory goes into this actually the bulk
of what we do in this study is theory
even though I'm talking about all these
results here i do want to at least give
a flavor of it so there is indeed lots
of lemmas and more lemmas and more
ulemas and theorems and algorithms and
more algorithms were theorems and were
theorems that's what we actually do to
get here but at the end what it does is
give us a way of dealing with these
multi scale processes so we can refine
our phylogenies take what we would get
with these earlier just rectilinear
Steiner tree models and correct them to
some degree so show that some cases
where it looked like maybe there was a
long chain of single probe changes is
more parsimoniously explained by let's
say an annual ploidy event a whole
genome duplication and we can therefore
get better trees it turns out this
doesn't actually dramatically change the
topology of the trees in general the
shape statistics aren't dramatically
different but it does give you a little
boost in predictive power for some of
these tasks you're better able two
distinct distinguished primary for
metastatic tumors seems that being able
to detect these aneuploidy events gives
you at least a little boost it's a hint
about whether you're looking at a
primary and metastatic tumor although it
doesn't help us in this crucial question
distinguishing a progressor primary from
a non progressor but that is just one
further step getting a slightly better
model gives a slightly more predictive
power we decided to go back to the
drawing board again and then say not
only do we have these different scales
of events but we also really should have
different rates of events different
genes are under different selective
pressures some positive some negatives
and strong some weak you may have
different preferences for gain or loss
at different scales within the genome
and these are going to be patient
specific different individuals while
different preferences for these kinds of
mutational processes both how they
generate diversity in the tumor and how
the selection occurs in the tumor so as
a next step we went back to the drawing
board developed a whole new body of
theory that let us work with models of
evolution with these different rates are
not telling you about all the algorithms
that go into that but basically we're
able to build phylogenetic trees that
can take advantage of these evolutionary
models come up with other kind of
expectation maximization approaches to
learn the evolutionary models on a
patient specific basis concurrent with
learning the trees and come up with
models that allow us to now infer these
patients specific evolutionary pressures
and even better trees that are
consistent with these so we can start
looking through different tumor types
through these populations and asking
what are these evolutionary pressures
that we learn how do they differ between
different stages of tumor development
and start seeing an interesting
differences how these selective
environment or how the selective
pressures are changing as we move
through tumor stages as well as how this
differs patient-to-patient across our
samples and see this through for
multiple different examples of these
kinds of paired tumors that actually
leads to more traumatic or more dramatic
changes in tree topology than the move
to the multi scale model which might
seem like a bigger change in the model
so allowing these waiting events
basically taking account of the
different rates leads to some greater
shifts and the topologies of the tumors
and that actually leads to more
significant boost in predictive power so
we're able to get better separation of
long versus short survivals these are
the tongue cancers again and we're able
to get better classification
prediction power and all these different
tasks and turns out that really the
strongest predictors across these
different tasks tend to be these overall
measures of the evolutionary process the
tree topology features or actually the
parameter values we learn themselves are
independently a very strong predictor
for some of these tasks like
distinguishing a primary from a
metastatic tumor so what all that does
is bring us to the point where we have
been able to develop tumor phylogeny
isn't quite a lot of tumors and I think
draw some interesting conclusions that
at least I think are reflective of a lot
of the conclusions and a lot of the
results that I've been hearing over the
course of this meeting so because we're
heading into a discussion session
because we've had so much exciting
discussion already on the question of
tumor evolution I had made some
last-minute changes to my talk just a
little while ago I decided to throw out
my standard sort of diplomatic
understated scientific conclusions and
try to take the speaker's prerogative as
the first person to get to weigh in on
our evolution discussion by giving you
instead my hyperbolic overstated
conclusions so the first thing I wanted
to say is that one of the big things we
can conclude from all of these tumor
phylogeny studies we've been doing over
the years is that there has been a ton
of work in tumor phylogenetics and most
of it is useless and the reason it's
useless is become and what's useless I'm
getting there but not joy kidding anyone
yeah well I'm explaining that so the
reason the reason most of us out there
is useless is because it's using the
wrong models the wrong algorithms in the
wrong data and the reason I'm saying
that is because although the overall
high level idea that we can understand
tumor evolution by using phylogenetic
tools that is a fantastic idea and a
very powerful idea you have to take
account of the fact that although
cancers evolved they do not evolve by
the same mechanisms as species or
individuals in a population and if you
don't take account of those mechanism
for example the dominance of structural
variations and copy number variations
you're not going to get a useful model
of most of what's happening in tumor
evolution you not only need the right
models you need algorithm suited to
these models and for the right models of
tumor evolution your standard
phylogenetic algorithms do not work you
can't make the kinds of assumptions you
would make when you're looking at a slow
varying point mutation process you need
to develop a new body of algorithms and
I can certainly say I'm very happy to be
in a room here with a very large
fraction of the people working on
developing the body of theory needed to
do this I think we all know that some of
us have made a beginning towards this
but there's an enormous amount of work
to do and it needs to be done and I will
say that if you don't understand that
you're not going to gather the right
data and I would say one of the biggest
challenges for the field today is that
the great majority of the people who've
joined the field and are working on it
don't understand these points at all
they have no idea why any of these
things would be important and they
certainly have no idea what to do about
any of them if they do realize they're
important so that's one of the reasons i
think this community is so important
there's a lot of work to be done and we
are the ones who are going to do and I
hope someone is going to see this video
and decide to join in on that process
with us the second thing I will say is
that we learn from looking at these
tumor phylogenies when you can look at
copy number variation you can look at
these single cells that to an
overwhelming degree tumor evolution is
random noise most of what you are seeing
is random variation I think this is
echoing a point christina was making
most of what you see is basically just
random diversification within the tumor
and when you have this random noise you
can't learn anything from looking at one
tumor phylogeny I think the field needs
to get away from this notion that you
can build a few tumor phylogeny and
start doing your story-telling about
them you're really not doing science
unless you're figuring out what is
statistically robust across these it's
like looking at clouds you're going to
see patterns and most of those patterns
are not going to be reproducible if
you're not doing this right as you go
through the
the final thing I want to say that I
think comes out of our studies and I i
think is relevant to quite a few of the
questions coming up is that I would say
and I'm not the first to say this by any
means that the focus on cancers is being
primarily a disease of proliferation or
tumor formation I think is a distraction
if you're talking about tumor evolution
the defining feature of cancers is hyper
mutability and I know there are
exceptions to this but I would say there
are the exceptions that prove the rule
there are a small number of cancers that
are more or less triggered by a single
mutation or a small number that trigger
a proliferation phenotype without a
hyper mutability phenotype and those are
the low-hanging fruits of cancer those
are going to be cured by targeted
therapeutics and that's certainly
important work but for the bulk of
tumors a hyper mutability phenotype very
often a chromosome instability phenotype
is the defining feature of the cancer
and everything else that happens
including tumor formation amplification
of driver genes or loss of driver genes
all of that or incidental side effects
of hyper mutability if you don't
understand the hyper mutability then
you're not going to understand how tumor
evolution works or how to treat cancers
in the presence of these kinds of hyper
mutability phenotypes so a lot of what
we're seeing is that that mutability
phenotype what Loeb called the mutator
phenotype is itself a powerful predictor
of future tumor progression fish is
giving us one window into that
phenomenon in a very incomplete one I
know others who are working in this
field are seeing the same thing from
other sorts of windows I think it's a
really crucial thing to bear in mind
when we're talking about tumor evolution
so I will just wrap up with some
acknowledgments this approach to single
cell tumor sequencing originally came
out of collaboration with my longtime
collaborator dr. Stanley Shack knee was
originally put in place by a former
student Gregory Pennington the bulk of I
was telling you about today came from
work of a more recent student to
graduate from my lab Salim chowdhury and
was done in collaboration with Alejandro
Schaefer and my Gertz at the NCBI and
Thomas read Kristen
samehada and Darryl the monks of the NCI
so thanks to our funders for various
aspects of this over the years and I
thank all of you for your attention so
just the month Tomas question or comment
about the one before last slide yeah
this for the discussion about anything
else your yeah I just had a question
about the rectilinear Steiner true
that's a hard problem actually right so
how did you do so few words about how
you actually do it yes it is an
intractable problem so we can't provably
solve it to optimality and that's where
these heuristics from phylogenetics come
in essentially what the prior theory
gives us is a character characterization
of possible Steiner nodes and optimal
trees that lets you greatly cut down the
space of Steiner nodes and then we use
that with more or less a version of
neighbor-joining where we use that
cutting down of the space to restrict or
not neighbor-joining the median joining
where we cut down the space of possible
medians and basically make it tractable
not to search that necessarily
exhaustively but to search medians
exhaustively and we can find empirically
on simulated data that almost always
gets you an optimal solution sometimes
just suboptimal
have a question but how many characters
you can actually have so many pros do
you have simultaneously are you asking
about the experimental technology of the
album well I'm probably not the best
person to answer that our collaborators
in the reed lab tell us there is no
upper limit essentially they can put a
bunch of probes on to the cell wash them
off put on new probes and find the same
cell i assume there actually is a
practical upper limit before that breaks
down but then they haven't told us what
that is in in the real datasets we have
available to us i think the largest we
have is this point 14 probes a lot of
the reaches that you work at for a probe
is it so what what's the level can
actually also look at point mutations or
is it no I don't think fish could see
point mutations again I'm not the expert
on that so I'm not a person to ask oh
the last comment about how half or about
half of cancers this type of mutator
phenotype you made the statement if
that's right it's a cause later actually
no or is it possible it's also a
consequence earlier events great for
instance one day me and this is just
anecdotal one and I don't know the
literature as well as say my rudders in
the room light but we others data that
were ordering the Vixen cancer we have
got the p53 must be early because in
fact of the hyper abusing your phenotype
authorities you know [ __ ] number
variations really there almost there in
a cinemark repeated injury activity and
so the Assumption had been thrust and
cooking cream us can't really call
creation event consumers to Olga and in
fact it as far as you can see the jury's
still out on that so was wondering
because any evidence that actually you
know are these copy number variations
causal for anything most the time
already just a random contemplates of
most of the cells already well I first
say that that is definitely not a proven
point so that that is part of the
overstated part of my overstated
conclusions I'd say it's a controversial
point in the literature or do you want
oil in a game steam game of tp53 again
it's not I'm ever going to presented
tomorrow it's not approve but I have the
result which I have a consistent with
the other way around exactly this adds
on no no that a generator of the s you
say that this versus the mutagenesis and
then we have tp53 so again this is a
statistical argument not caught in
action little bad but it's for a subset
of breast cancer another setback but a
and the mission cancer we can see it's
that upper back is before p53
yes look probably to spend on cancer it
depends on the cancer there are there
the vogelstein model has p53 very late
we've looked in squamous cell carcinoma
skin and we are with our timing
algorithms we've been pretty compelling
evidence that p53 is amongst the
earliest 5% of lesions show it is almost
certainly tumor dependent and the
mutator phenotype yeah it I in sir it
differs by cancer and also the source of
the mutator phenotype differs so p53 is
the most common one but it's not the
only one and yeah hi I'll leave that for
this discussion period in the machine
learning approach when you associated to
the clinical outcomes and progression
and son did you look at this predictor
individual because they will not be
independent I assumed they are very
highly correlated probably so the
teacher says they sort of the
multivariate setting so on yeah so we
did some experiments with feature
selection to see if there were subsets
of these features that were more
strongly predictive I don't think I have
the results on these slides so that
there are some subsets that are a little
more strongly predictive than the full
feature said but basically I guess the
way I would summarize is that the number
of probes were looking and therefore the
number of features is not large enough
to conclude too much from any one
feature although you can pick out like
some of the genes are more individually
predictive of let's say primary versus
metastasis there are some genes that are
amplified selectively in metastasis and
that are themselves strong predictors
okay thank you also